[Music]
as you know every year Animal Planet
airs the Puppy Bowl for people who don't
watch the Super Bowl yeah and every year
since we realized Animal Planet couldn't
sue us we've done a puppy version of
this show called puppy
Conan ladies and gentlemen please
welcome back by popular demand puppy
Conan
[Applause]
there's puppy Conan good and that's that
is what Andy and I do during the
commercial breaks
is wrong
puppy Andy has been drinking alright
puppy Conan's first guest it's nice to
him to stop by even though he's about to
play in the Super Bowl its puppy Tom
Brady let's get him out here yes that is
a deflated football there's
puppy Conan desperately trying to get
order and control over the show here's
our next guest this week he formed a
pack to look into running for president
in 2016 please welcome puppy New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
one of the bad people pick that now this
is more like ryokan and I never cut okay
until we stop this madness
ladies and gentlemen here's our final
guest she's had an amazing year we're
lucky to get her puppy Nicki Minaj's on
the show
[Applause]
apologies all around everybody involved
what a freak show
you